considera la función fx igual a 1 entre
x cuadrada menos k x donde k es una
constante distinta de 0 la derivada de
la función f está dada por f prima de x
igual acá menos 2x / x cuadrada menos
acá x todo esto elevado al cuadrado y
está de lujo porque además nos dan la
derivada eso es bastante agradable ya
que nos ahorrará tiempo inciso a si acá
vale 3 entonces
fx es igual a 1 entre x cuadrada menos
3x observa que aquí en el valor de cap
pusieron el valor de 3 muy bien escribe
la ecuación para la recta tangente a la
gráfica efe en el punto cuya coordenada
x es 4 ahora bien si nos piden la
ecuación de una recta bueno pues esta
ecuación va a ser de la forma bien es
igual
m x + b donde m es la pendiente y p la
intersección con el eje y ahora la
pendiente de la recta tangente que
queremos aquí es lo mismo que la
derivada de ye con respecto a x evaluado
en el punto que nos dan es decir nos
dicen que x es igual a 4 entonces
podemos decir que la pendiente en este
caso va a ser igual a la derivada de la
función evaluada en x igual a 4 y bueno
si observas esto me va a quedar aquí
tengo acá pero acá vale 3
entonces me quedarían tres menos dos por
x pero estamos evaluando en x igual a 4
entonces me quedaría 2 x 4 muy bien ya
esto lo vamos a dividir entre x cuadrada
pero recuerda estoy evaluando en el
punto x igual a 4
entonces me va a quedar 4 del cuadrado
menos
x bueno acá vale 3 y xv al de 4 en el
punto donde estoy evaluando esto elevado
al cuadrado y bueno lo único que hice es
sustituir el valor de acá igual a 3 ene
efe prima de x me quedaría 3 - 2 x entre
x cuadrada menos 3 x todo eso elevado al
cuadrado y después evalúen en x igual a
4 así que en lugar de x puse a 4 en su
reemplazo y entonces esto que va a ser
igual me queda 3 menos 8 y abajo me
queda 16 y esto es 12 entonces 3 menos 8
eso es lo mismo que menos 5 y en la
parte de abajo me va a quedar 16 - 12
es 4 al cuadrado es 16 bien lo podemos
escribir así la pendiente en este caso
va a ser menos 5 dieciseisavos
bien ahora ya que tenemos a la pendiente
como podemos encontrar también ave bueno
pues para encontrar a ver vamos a usar
las coordenadas cuando x vale 4 cuanto
vale y entonces primero encontremos el
valor del yen bueno pues ya es lo mismo
que fx entonces me va a quedar
efe de equis pero esta vez vamos a
fijarnos en el punto donde x es igual a
4 por lo tanto vamos a buscar allí
cuando x vale 4 ok entonces lo que voy a
hacer es evaluar en esta función cuando
x vale 4 y me va a quedar lo mismo que 1
entre bueno 4 al cuadrado lo cual es 16
menos 3 por 4 lo cual es 12 es decir que
ya toma el valor de un cuarto cuando x
vale 4 eso es muy importante y ahora que
ya tenemos que llevarle un cuarto x vale
4 y que la pendiente vale menos 5
y 6 a vos entonces ahora vamos a buscar
a ver y la vamos a buscar sustituyendo
estos valores en esta ecuación que tengo
aquí es decir me va a quedar que sí que
vale un cuarto
esto es igual a la pendiente que es
menos cinco dieciseisavos que multiplica
a equis pero x vale 4 + b
lo único que hice fue primero usar a efe
prima evaluada en 4 para así obtener la
pendiente eso es muy importante entonces
si acá vale a 3 y xv al 4 sustituir esos
valores aquí yo obtuve estar pendiente y
después me di cuenta que ya tenía x pero
no tenía ayer y por lo tanto no podíamos
obtener a ver pero para obtener alguien
lo que hice fue recordar que es igual a
fx pero lo quiero evaluado en este punto
que es el punto que vive en mi recta
tangente y entonces evalúe a fx cuando x
vale 4 y lo hice justo aquí y entonces
me quedo que ya valía un cuarto es decir
cuando x vale 4 que vale 14 ok y ahora
utilizo también la información de la
pendiente la pendiente vale menos 5
dieciseisavos y así voy a obtener a ver
y ya que tenga ya la pendiente ya tendré
la ecuación de la recta así que
hagámoslo aquí me va a quedar un cuarto
es igual y aquí tengo menos 5 por 4
entre 16 bueno puede reducir un poco 4
entre 16 es un cuarto por menos 5 me va
a quedar menos cinco cuartos ok
más b eso quiere decir que va a ser
igual y voy a sumar menos cinco cuartos
de ambos lados y me va a quedar un
cuarto este de aquí más 54 o dicho de
otra manera b es lo mismo que seis
cuartos o ver esto se puede reducir me
quedaría tres medios o también lo
podemos ver como 1.5 muy bien ya tengo a
ver es este valor de aquí también ya
tengo la pendiente que es esta que tengo
aquí por lo tanto ya puedo escribir la
ecuación de mi recta mi recta va a ser
de la forma james es igual a la
pendiente por equis pero ya sabemos que
la pendiente vale menos cinco
dieciseisavos
esto que multiplica a x + b&b valen 1.5
ahora si lo queremos escribir todo en
fracciones entonces podemos decir que ya
es igual a menos cinco dieciseisavos de
x más y bueno voy a poner tres medios
porque 1.5 es lo mismo que tres medios y
ya con esto hemos acabado esta es la
ecuación de la recta tangente que
estábamos buscando y con esto hemos
acabado el inciso a